when most people think about an old
growth forest they think of a really
unique and special place huge mature
trees and all sorts of
species interacting
old growth grasslands are the same they
have also taken centuries to develop and
the grasses and the plants in those
systems are also really large really old
but other size is below ground
it's hard to tell the difference between
an old growth and young grassland but
trained eyes can see key differences
like higher biodiversity and a world of
Wonder Underground
the Deep Roots organs and seed banks in
grasslands help them bounce back after
disturbances
we are getting more and more information
that the ecosystem services that
grasslands provide are as as great as
the ecosystem Services the forests
provide we're starting to understand the
incredible carbon that is stored below
ground in grasslands but these complex
systems face significant threats in some
regions like the Cerrado in Brazil and
North America's Great Plains more than
half of grasslands have been cleared for
farmland and tree plantations
so how do researchers restore damaged
grasslands to their former glory a
review in science lays out what
scientists have tried so far and the
questions yet to be answered
there's a technique that's widely used
in temperate Europe that's heat transfer
that's when you collect the hay on one
pristine grassland to transfer it to
another one that's degraded
hay transfer is effective in grasslands
with annual species that produce viable
seeds every year
we also tried in some degraded grassland
in Brazil it did not work at all over
there because in Brazil the grassland I
worked in are mainly composed of
perennial species perennial species
don't have the same regular cycles of
seed production as annuals some only
create seeds on occasion like after a
fire others rely more heavily on their
root system to reproduce this makes
establishing perennial plants quite the
challenge in grasslands
those are ones that we're seeing more
and more that they need to be part of
the grassland system for a really
successful recovery to occur so how do
we do it do we actually have to
transplant individuals do we have to put
in some of those root fragments those
are all ideas that have potential value
in addition to losing native species
some grasslands have also lost the
disturbances that maintain them like
fire and grazing
these are crucial to preserving their
biodiversity and preventing trees from
colonizing
it's very important to understand the
reason at which you have to apply this
disturbance you cannot apply
the disturbance regime that you
understood for the pristine grassland
right away because the vegetation is not
the same you're gonna have to adapt your
disturbance regime as the restoration
goes and as species colonize or as we
introduce species yourself there's one
experiment where we grew some plants for
a number of months and years
and then we burn them at different age
to see what age they needed to be to be
transplanted in the wild and be able to
sustain fire
because it doesn't make any sense to
transplant six month seedlings that are
gonna die with the first fire that we
cannot control
there's many ways to have to iterate and
have to intervene along that recovery
Church Factory to have success and that
just assembling putting in the desired
elements and then walking away probably
won't be successful in many of these
grasslands
as a College's work out how to monitor
and manage restored grasslands they also
hope to preserve old growth grasslands
that remain intact I'm hoping that
people think about what type of agenda
we can put forward to actually better
maintain and protect these incredibly
special old growth grasslands that are
on the Earth
look
foreign
[Music]